>> Laura: IT’S EASY TO BECOME
NUMB TO MEDIA BIAS THESE DAYS,
THE INGRAHAM ANGLE IS KEEPING
TRACK OF THE WORST OFFENDERS
EVERY WEEK.
JOINING ME IS ADAM WILL LET, THE
PRESIDENT OF ACCURACY AND MEDIA.
GREAT TO SEE YOU.
LET’S BEGIN WITH CNN DON LEMON,
YOU GUYS ARE GOOD FRIENDS.
HE IS CLAIMING TO KNOW THE REAL
REASON THE WHITE HOUSE WASN’T
HOLDING THEIR DAILY COVID PRESS
BRIEFING.
>> ACTUALLY PAY ATTENTION TO
WHAT IS HAPPENING IN WASHINGTON
WITH THIS ADMINISTRATION.
NOT HAVING THE BRIEFING,
PRETENDING THAT THIS IS OVER.
THEY WANT TO MOVE ONTO OTHER
THINGS.
SO NOT HAVING THOSE BRIEFINGS,
THAT IS ALL PART OF THE PLAN FOR
YOU TO THINK THAT THIS IS OVER.
>> Laura: CNN COMPLAINED,
DIDN’T THEY COMPLAINED THAT
BRIEFINGS WERE A WASTE OF TIME?
LEMON SPECIFICALLY SAID BAIT
SHOULDN’T EVEN BE TAKEN AS LIVE
EVENTS, SO NOW WHY IS HE WHINING
AT THEM?
>> IT’S UNBELIEVABLE, COGNITIVE
DISSONANCE OF TWO OPPOSING
VIEWPOINTS AT THE SAME TIME.
WHAT IS THE TERM FOR HOLDING TWO
OPPOSING VIEWPOINTS?
QUESTION THE
SAME WEEK?
THEY ARE FOR, AGAINST, LITERALLY
WHATEVER POSITION TRUMP TAKES
THEY WRITE THEIR COPY AGAINST
IT.
>> Laura: IT’S SO GOOFY.
THERE IS NO OTHER ISSUE
HAPPENING IN THE ENTIRE WORLD,
IT’S IMPORTANT BUT THERE ARE
OTHER ISSUES THEY HAVE TO GET
TO.
IT’S CRAZY.
BUT THEY WANT TO STAY IN THIS
PERPETUAL PANIC MODE BECAUSE
THEY THINK THAT IS GOOD FOR
THEIR RATINGS OR MAY BE BAD FOR
TRUMP, I DON’T KNOW WHAT THEIR
ANALYSIS IS.
A "NEW YORK MAGAZINE" REPORTER
DOESN’T UNDERSTAND THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN LOSING PEOPLE
IN A WAR VERSUS A PANDEMIC.
SPEAK UP IF AN AMERICAN
PRESIDENT LOSES MORE AMERICANS
OVER THE COURSE OF SIX WEEKS THE
DIED IN THE ENTIRETY OF THE
VIETNAM WAR, DOES HE DESERVE TO
BE REELECTED?
>> A LOT OF THE FOLKS MADE THIS
COMPARISON THIS WEEK, WE HAVE
HAD REALLY BAD FLU SEASONS THAT
HAVE HAD ALMOST THAT AMOUNT OF
DEAD PEOPLE.
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT.
>> IT’S UNBELIEVABLE, FIRST THEY
WANTED TO MAKE THIS TRUMP’S
KATRINA.
NOW THEY ARE TRYING TO MAKE IT
TRUMP’S VIETNAM.
ANY MINUTE, THEY WILL START
PUTTING THE CALENDAR IN THE
BOTTOM CORNER OF THE SCREEN WITH
THE DEATH EACH DAY.
RACHEL MADDOW IS GOING TO START
TELLING PEOPLE THE PANDEMIC IS
NOW UNWINNABLE AND DISTRIBUTING
CYANIDE TABLETS FOR HER VIEWERS
TO PUT IN THEIR COMPUTER.
THEIR OVERSTATEMENT OF THIS IS
OUTRAGEOUS.
>> Laura: HERE IS OBAMA’S
FORMER CAMPAIGN MANAGER TRYING
TO REWRITE HISTORY.
>> THERE’S A REAL DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE MEDIA LOOKING INTO
THESE ALLEGATIONS, WHICH IS WHAT
THEY HAVE DONE TARA READE AND
BRETT KAVANAUGH, AND MITCH
McCONNELL WHO GOT THAT PROCESS
OVER AS FAST AS HE COULD GET IT
OVER WITH TO PROTECT THE
NOMINEE.
>> Laura: ADAM, YOU NOTICED HE
GOT NO PUSHBACK FOR THAT CLAIM.
>> NO, THEY HAVE THE
INTELLECTUAL INTEGRITY OF THE
CAST OF ROSE McGOWAN,